hey guys Ryan right here Mitchell
alright so tonight I am going to watch
the trailer with Caroline to a movie
called Annie have you seen the original
yes you have I honestly have not seen
the original do you sing you don't you
sing no are you afraid I'm gonna ask you
think did you also do your eyebrows yeah
so your hair matches your eyebrow that's
a very exotic look I cannot believe I'm
looking at you right she's back on the
channel naked again as always and that's
what we bring you're here for just to be
naked we don't really care about her
opinions and stuff it's more about the
sex appeal
ain't that right Caroline yeah whatever
works whatever works she thinks she's
getting paid but she's not whatever
you'll get money one day you'll get
money one day would you ever consider
doing prostitution yeah okay well I
guess I got an extra 500 bucks it's done
alright guys so let's watch this trailer
Cameron Diaz Jamie Foxx little black
girl forgot what movie she's in but a
little black girls are cool that does
not sound cool little black yeah yeah
she's gonna buy like the Hannigan yeah
tomorrow
black dick he thought she was okay yeah
okay I could go for a hooker sex I miss
sex people okay so that was a great
trailer I loved the original Annie and I
like the modern-day take on it I love
Jamie Foxx I like Cameron Diaz and I
love the little black girl now okay Rose
Byrne yeah Rose Byrne is awesome I love
Rose Byrne she's gorgeous and she's a
wonderful actress in funny oh yeah
neighbors she was awesome in that film
Jamie Foxx hilarious Django Unchained
gosh the comedy was Hillary for sure
this one's cute yeah Christmas man I
can't wait for a the Annie is using the
eye
did you catch on to that yeah yeah I can
pull it together I can pull it together
yeah we have a thing to do we have to
film this video yeah for you guys
because you guys wanted us to watch this
trailer it's really good I like it no it
is it's a really good for us do you
dance
no do you what kind of workouts did you
a very very strenuous is everything you
say just come across sexual is that or
some reason whatever it comes out of
your mouth I'm just like sex is all it's
okay whatever this is probably just mean
it's not you okay guys over knee to the
channel subscribe yeah hey support the
subscribe button would you please
support the subscribe button yeah it's
right here yeah just support the button
you don't have to click it we just
really like them yeah there you go see
that is a sexual thing you guys that
could be boobs upside down or balls okay
auntie yeah exactly
it's a giant balls right there that
would be scary
the bows of a while
alright guys subscribe alright so it's
that time of this video where people
really care people don't care about the
trailers no one cares about the trailers
they just want to hear their names shout
it out need that right kids cédric house
he said can I get a shout out because
you're the [ __ ] you hear that Caroline
I'm the [ __ ] Thank You Cedric [ __ ] you
said that would confidence Thank you
Thank You Cedric
yeah I'm Carolina found the [ __ ] how
come you won't give me a chance Caroline
what the hell what what am I missing
here I got an awesome body literally the
face too good to be true sense of humor
check penis size just the right amount
minor check mark come on what more do
you need from a guy I'm a hard worker
okay whatever it Caroline happy life oh
whatever
private life Armand Arnoff Abdul raw
your name cut off sorry bro
guys I love you so much I really hope
you guys give me a shout-out Ryan
freaking love you love you guys
yours sincerely some 12 year old hoods a
12 year old sup 12 year old that was 12
that's when I discovered porn 10 or 11
or 12 actually my dad had a big closet
full of porn I think times have changed
Ryan I think children discovered porn I
like techno yeah yeah yeah no totally
especially with like you know the
internet now oh yeah pornhub.com you too
Freddie
not saying that you should god were
terrible role models what the hell is
wrong with you I I'm sorry but [ __ ]
Ryan I want him to go down the st. that
sounded like a sex thing [ __ ] Ryan
Ryan Ryan
yeah say that again so I couldn't repeat
it that voice of my oh yeah like I'm
gonna keep that in my head all night can
we go on yeah anyway - love you too man
you're awesome grow up and then go to a
strip club
maybe you one day I'll get a chick like
Caroline and then life will be good and
you gotta give me some tips tabs cuz she
won't give me any tips David Melgar
another 12 year old everybody right I am
12 years old I guess in the most of the
fanbase or 12 year olds now I am 12
years old and I
your videos can you shout out to me that
will be awesome oh and I'm also Latino
what up what up ese that was racist the
[ __ ] it were going with that
no god you're a cool Latino man Latinos
are awesome I like are you let you know
no where are you exactly
really Oh congratulations thank you you
know I learned the other day it is not
just me maybe in a sex calm it Russia so
in Russia the number of Hawaiian born
search is Russian girls actually like
they move Russia yeah like they look up
Russian girls Russian this Russian
there's a specific type in Russian
that's interesting yeah so you I guess
they know what's good yeah exactly
so yeah David Melgar um can you blow a
kiss for David now take it hi David
bye David have you